[Music]
nathan come on
let's go but the sky's on fire
okay we're good yeah
you can see it from here
oh god none of them got called
two days they got it all wrong there's a
[ __ ] ton of fragments on that thing
they're saying that one of them is a
planet killer and now they've grounded
all non-military flights i mean what do
we do
i don't even know if the shelter
relocation thing is real
just [ __ ] and you know it
i'm sorry okay i'm sorry it's just just
please give us a call
if you find out anything when you get
there look where we can go to be safe
you know i will
the only thing people want to talk about
today is this clark this uh
interstellar comic right big news
i don't see clark oh maybe he's still
sleeping
dad some of clark's larger fragments are
now expected to enter
our atmosphere that's right and now
those are just what are they saying
more of the same
where are they going i don't know
when first chunks is about to hit ants
only part of it let's go in the ocean
but you look at that
hey where's explosion
we now are getting word that the
fragment has skipped
central florida wait are some more
pieces gonna hit
come on let's go put the sky's on fire
two days they got it all wrong there's a
ton of fragments planet killers
space agencies are predicting an
extinction-level event
we're going to be together all right get
them we're just trying to get to safety
they've been tracking the military
flights to bunkers and greenland
it's our only chance
[Music]
[Music]
if you are hearing this broadcast seek
shelter immediately
what's going on
shelter immediately seek shelter
immediately
[Music]
you